jane robinson bonsoir merci d'avoir cet
élève lévitation de 24,60 euros soit
votre ordre du jour quelle a été votre
réaction monsieur robinson lorsque vous
avez pris connaissance de ce jugement
que l'on qualifie déjà d'historique
aujourd'hui ben on la jouera quelques
sons globale sur deux de joie et surtout
hommage profond à la mémoire de mon ami
super eagles qui a vraiment mis ce
questions sur l'agenda national il ya
plus de deux ans en moi c'était les
premiers profits oui elle a fait elle
est morte presque 21 ans jour pour jour
elle est morte 12 février 1994 et une
semaine avant sa mort elle quitte à lui
comparaître à la chambre des communes
pour plaider la cause au delà même la
cour suprême elle disait je ne voudrais
pas que ce combat soit mené en vain que
ce combat donne des résultats
alors qu'un sentiment aujourd'hui vous
habite à ce résultat
oui évidemment c'était une très très
longue journée
c'est pas facile mais évidemment le
résultat est vraiment historique sans
précédent au niveau de benko d'une cour
d'un cours nationales comme la cour
suprême du canada
et moi j'étais avec soi quand on a reçu
le vieux de premier jugement de la cour
suprême c'était au mois de septembre 93
et je n'oublierai jamais elle me dit bon
du port-vieux personnel la cour a
tranché mais c'est moi qui a le dernier
mot et c'est bien sûr le cas mais aussi
nous nous étions tous les deux d'accord
que même si on avait perdu ce jugement
que on allait un jour gagner la victoire
est ce ce jour est arrivé aujourd'hui et
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment magnifique
et je dois dire que c'est c'est grâce à
sous mais aussi aux autres autres
personnes très courageux je pense par
exemple à mon amie francine lalonde qui
arrêt lutté pendant longtemps pour cette
cette question le député steven fois tu
qu'il est aujourd'hui
deux chambres pour des chansons de la
loi et évidemment les personnes qui ont
qui sont allés jusqu'à la cour suprême
maintenance et c'est vraiment rookie qui
mérite un ange vraiment profond quel
courage fallait-il à l'époque assure
rodriguez pour mener ce combat qui
dépassait sa propre cause en france la
propre situation personnelle souhaitée
une femme vraiment extraordinaire
c'était s'était pas seulement son
courage de 2 10 roulent
il me reste peut être deux ans trois ans
maximum et je vais je vais consacrer
tout ce temps de lutter trop ce
changement mais de lutter d'une façon
publique ce n'était pas facile
elle avait un jeune 6 son mari mais elle
a mis sa fille devant la public canadien
et ça c'était vraiment extraordinaire et
là la réponse est aussi vraiment
encourageant mais c'était surtout je
crois c'est sa passion dignité qui avait
pour beaucoup canadiens et canadiennes
pour la première fois ils ont compris ce
que c'était
le droit de mourir dans la dignité ça
c'était grâce le jugement semble encore
à connaître les douaniers originale de
sauvagerie gaza savoir justement quand
le droit de mourir dans la dignité
et c'est le droit de ces le droit à la
vie ce n'est pas l'obligation de vivre
mais c'est le droit à la vie ou est-ce
qu'elle avait puisé cette conviction la
bon je crois que pendant 2 le droit de
vie pour elle l'essentiel pour moi aussi
comme comme son ami et défenseurs des
deux mêmes objectifs de changer la loi
c'est vraiment une question de droit de
chaque personne de décider soi-même
quand le moment où la vie perdre sa
valeur a ici c'est ce qu'a reconnu la
cour suprême dans son jugement que c'est
une question ont ils ont cité la charte
des droits et libertés a le droit à la
vie mais la vie n'importe mais pas une
vie n'importe quoi mais une vie de
dignité sans souffrance et c'était pour
ça que ce avait lutté spécial que la
cour a reconnu aujourd'hui et pour ceux
et celles invoquées l époque parce qu'à
l'époque on tient beaucoup à la question
des personnes vulnérables des personnes
handicapées et tous ces risques de
dérapage début de personnes vulnérables
la cour semble dire aujourd'hui que les
personnes handicapées ont droit
on mêmes droits que les personnes qui ne
le sont pas on a même autonomie le même
droit à la vie de même droit à la
sécurité
donc pour ceux qui craignent des
dérapages qu'est-ce que vous le redis je
leur dit deux choses d'abord de comme la
cour suprême avait dit et comme la corse
près de la colonie britannique
la juge de smet avait dit dans son
jugement
original qui avait été soutenu par la
cour suprême de de voir la réalité dans
les juridictions où ça existe qui s'est
pressée prédictions de d'abus tout ça
que kiné qui n'était pas bien fondé
quand en effet c'est un très très petit
nombre de personnes qui qui prendra qui
utilisent cette possibilité et surtout
qu' il faut quand même respecter et
essaie de comprendre les craintes des
personnes handicapées parce que vous
savez que plusieurs organismes nationaux
de représentants des personnes
handicapées se sont exprimés contre
jugement mais je leur dis que et mes
meilleurs mais il ya une des visions sur
rodriguez elle-même était profondément
handicapée
le député steven fletcher lui-même et
handicapées et l'essentiel pour moi
c'est qu' on respecte les droits des
personnes handicapées
mais on respecte aussi leur choix comme
le choix de tous les autres personnes de
décider concept assez et l'importance
d'établir des balises la cour suprême le
souligne également les balises sont une
protection suffisante selon vous contre
ces risques de dérapage
oui oui absolument et on ne commence pas
au début de cette question parce que sur
aux questions de balises par exemple il
n'y a plus d'autres juridictions
la belgique luxembourg deux autres sur
réduction qui ont établi des valises le
québec par exemple
comme vous le savez bien le québec
adopté une loi récemment avec l'appui
des deux presque tous les députés qui
contient des balises important et je
protège je souligne le fait que la la
comme dans plusieurs autres questions si
le québec était bien en avant sur la
question de mourir dans la dignité
sur la question de droit à l'avortement
sur la question des droits des gays et
lesbiennes
c'était le québec qui était en avant sur
cette question aussi et après ça pour
moi monsieur robinson
qu'est ce que ce jugement aujourd'hui
vous permettrait de dire de rêver
et 21 heures à la mort de sourire de
rigueur parce qu'à la chambre des
communes en 97 vous disiez qu'elle est
morte
grâce au soutien d'un médecin courageux
qui a pris le risque d'encourir des
accusations criminelles
c'est le plus grand secret qui entoure
cet événement lors on comprend par
délicatesse mais qu'est ce que ce
jugement là où aujourd'hui nous
permettre de lever le voile sur certains
aspects de ce moment là ce serait
possible bien sûr mais moi je préfère de
parler de la vie de se réveiller et pas
de sa mort parce que c'était surtout sa
vie et sa présence s'agit courageuse sa
vie de patience avides de convection de
de courage que sa mémoire que je crois
que les canadiens soutiennent de deux
pas et pas des détails de ce mort non
pas penser aussi que pour le médecin
dont on ne connaît pas l'identité
aujourd'hui ça peut être un très grand
soulagement pour cette personne là aussi
si le résultat d'un combat pour tous les
médecins et il y a n'oublions jamais
qu'il y a beaucoup de médecins qui
depuis des années ont respecté le droit
de leur passion et ont respecté leur
leur désir de de mettre fin à l'orgie
mais ils l'ont fait dans la
clandestinité ils l'ont fait dans
l'illégalité
pour tous ces médecins courageux je dis
bravo
et maintenant heureusement ils vont
pouvoir travailler dans ce sens ont peur
et aussi comme vous le dites avec les
balises nécessaires
une journée de fête et une victoire de
vraiment de compassion de d'humanité de
de justice de ce jugement c'est vraiment
jugement historique
la cour suprême dit qu'il faudra
reconnaître la liberté de conscience des
médecins
peut-être un jour appelé à faire
de l'aide médicale à mourir mais on
entend des médecins dire que que c'est
tout c'est un jour sombre pour la
médecine
incapable de bien soigner de mener à
terme d'accompagner les patients c'est
l'échec des soins palliatifs aussi pour
certains oui et c'est pour ça pour cette
raison qu'il est absolument essentiel
que qu'on appuie plus de ressources que
les soins palliatifs c'est pas et
souvent on repose groupe comme si
c'était un départ entre les soins
palliatifs et le droit de mourir dans la
dignité l'aide au suicide assisté à
celui ci s'est pas qu'à moi j'ai appuyé
depuis le début souvent louis gay
avaient appuyé depuis le début les soins
palliatifs et beaucoup de mettre
beaucoup de ressources dans les soins
mais comme la cour suprême l'a souligné
comme soul a souligné il y a des gens
pour lesquels les bears ont installé
hâtif du monde de met pas fin à leurs
souffrances
et pour ces gens là un petit nombre mais
un nombre important pour nos familles
pour leurs proches
aujourd'hui et la cour suprême a dit
qu'ils respectent leurs doigts et ça
c'est vraiment vraiment important 1
termine à m qu'est ce que l'histoire va
retenir de surat un gain je crois que
l'histoire va retenir l'histoire d'une
femme qui vraiment mener une bataille au
niveau national avec courage avec
dignité avec l'humanité patients et qui
a commencé un voyage qui qui a mené
aujourd'hui à une victoire dans la cour
suprême pour justement profonde humanité
et ça c'est vraiment pour moi cette
c'est une femme outil vraiment mérite
tout notre respect et le jugement
aujourd'hui la cour suprême moi je suis
convaincu n'aurait jamais être rendue
sans le courage
et le leadership de tous où il y a plus
de raison une dernière question
peut-être un peu plus politiques
savaient que la majorité des juges de la
cour suprême ont été nommés par le
gouvernement et que le gouvernement du
canada est intervenu dans cette cause
pour contrer l'abolition de cet article
241 du code criminel souhaitait le
maintien de la prohibition de l'aide
médicale à mourir qu'est ce que ça vous
dit son injustice monstrueuse que tu vas
me dire c'est que leur triomphe et que
les politiciens qui ne respectent pas la
chape et doit des libertés que ce soit
ceux dans ce dossier ou dans d'autres
dossiers très importants sur lesquels
les la cour suprême s'est prononcée
récemment ciblé les parlementaires ne
respectent pas ces principes
fondamentaux le fait valeurs
fondamentaux du canada que la cour va
insister sur ce
et ce serait on parle de suicide assisté
médical mais je vous dis que ce serait
suicidaire politique pour un député un
parlementaire aujourd'hui de décès de
bloquer ce jugement historique de la
cour suprême est donc ainsi pour vous si
tout ce combat était à faire enfin
imaginer que vous ne rateriez sans aucun
doute c'était un privilège énorme de de
travailler avec avec sur rodriguez que
de revenir à miami de ce mode rieuse
mais aussi de rencontrer beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres gens comme francine
lalonde ce qui va me facturer et d'autre
pendant ce voyage
aujourd'hui c'est une grande victoire
mais il reste du travail à faire et pour
moi vraiment gmail et pas mal de combats
pendant mes 25 ans de deux députés mais
pour moi
au point de vue du point de vue
personnel humaine cette victoire est une
des places de plus d'importantes sera
benson merci beaucoup de nous avons
parlé de votre grande amie sur rodrigues
et du combat qu'a mené en votre
compagnie merci beaucoup
le flux vous madame tussauds